welcome to this video playing a new
blitz game here on the ICC five-minute
blitz against the gap on da cunha let me
check this guru move are you okay yeah
I've played as plating before he's a
specialist on the old Indian okay I was
transposing to the Kings Indian this is
sarah said didn't expect really but okay
Queenie seven young we've got we've
played a classical here with an IBD
seven and he's gotten on Queenie seven
what kind of mood was that hmm i don't
really know it okay I guess I'll protect
you for for the time being dumb other
than that stop stay out stay flexible
yeah i might play Knight g4 at some
point Bishop g5 okay maybe then some
more protection to the center
mmmh six-year you might play Knight g4
and this could could be a true I'd in
annoyance I don't want to play h3 really
hmm 83 looks but we had after the
capture at 95 as i'd like to have f3 in
this case and yeah well it's probably
not the most testing move button I don't
really know what to do under these
circumstances at least my pieces fit
reasonably well with the caption okay
what I'd like to do is to go be4 c5 and
put a piece on c4 night on c4 or bishop
on c4 the ice going for that probably
the night will go to e6 night a for
Bishop of 196 is probably what's going
to happen but ok I want to play before
NC 5 if I get this in this is not done
not a problem at all for watch the
bishop goes to have one yeah not really
because it's such a great piece but it
lent some protection to through the
kingside to the g2 and h three points
night on f4 is aggressively placed but i
don't think he can go for the direct
attack anytime soon and done alright it
looks to me like i'm getting be 45 in
him yeah that's aggressive of course
takes Knight takes Knight 83 might might
be the idea the thing is I can take it
yeah I guess I will
just want to get rid of this night and
then what now this now gives me a very
nice structure on the Kings side but ok
is bishop is strong should i go for be
45 now well i guess so yeah take off
should be too not sure there may be
happy to
the bishop on f3 would at least lend
very reliable protection to the Kings
side it's a somewhat okay this is
interesting i wonder if actually be five
as a movie em it looks it looks very
weakening but i get the perfect where
three actors make sense that connection
to the birth the bishop coming to f3
maybe even bishop 103-94 pressurizing
the queenside a three would take player
bouquet three this is quite annoying
want to keep them if are closed it looks
a bit strange because it retains the
dark squares but on the other hand that
gives me some play on the light squares
yeah this is actually i'm an interesting
move i was thinking about that okay
let's cover the important square cm
maybe I should have taken first actually
would have been interesting if I go here
now and play night to d4 is this a
possibility to take here and play a
really on the lights curse i love the
other that my time is obviously limited
no here and always take on c8 maybe
maybe you can actually no no we can't I
thought it could maybe take on deform
play something like you should be six
then but ok giving up this Bishop looks
really strange ok so i have really i
have some pressure on on the c6 bond if
term feels like a good position to me
but it's of course very very complicated
i can easily i might easily overlooked
something ok we can do look d8 but i
thought i'll just take CA take f 50
interesting mmm the queen is protected
here Bishop d for the sort of semi semi
threat it's not
okay let's start with that yeah maybe
you can actually play Bishop takes d4
yeah maybe 34 Queenie for tix rook takes
Knight c3 is always always possible okay
let's let's go here and force the
straight time warning and 93 m okay
check
tending 93 here maybe he's got rooked
the aid that could be good beer okay
well a disruptive honest there's no
threat that's important and there would
be six on that
now that that's a very dry way to play
but if he goes somewhere on the
sixth-ranked I have 93 this is fine if
he takes rook c6 is ok for me at least
but ok I've got I've got some some
problems on the clock
could have hmm could have gone 93
earlier this would have been better even
okay but this is just okay for me no
problem at all check
35 seconds check you are our third what
your declining a draw here I yo you must
what what is sick what is sick person
yeah yeah you have you have people
absolutely dunno what to do with the
time obviously now that's very exciting
and shows your abilities as a chess
player and qualities as a person yeah
well I had to have to hunch that they
have changed some games like that before
completely pointless really check
I won't press the draw button here buddy
maybe lose on time dry no he's now he
has pressed it noticing that it's even
really slow at pre moving unbelievable
stuff yo of the game itself from the
game itself was so was rather
interesting here in the in the middle
game I mean this is a very interesting
type of position where I don't really
know how to assess it it first sight you
might think that black should be okay
with this nice bush event and so on but
he also has a number of weaknesses I am
I'm really unsure let's look at this how
the computer says why does almost
winning here well that's that's really a
bit much maybe I mr. missed a couple of
things this is of course very much purse
possible are here okay I can take him
interesting I need to go back like
hundred move because of this idiocy at
the end
so here what can I can do that okay okay
but it's a tactical shot happening yeah
maybe why does really better it's it's
possible i mean i have i have the better
my pieces are just working better here
I've got the rook and this rook are both
doing things and black has really adds a
bad structure what it seems then that 94
is really bad i mean in comparison it's
it's obviously bad all this I don't know
it should probably be equal why I doubt
that there is something yes sirree is
happening here yeah this position is
just just very equal check check go
again hahaha that's you but okay yeah
Bishop of three of course picking up the
night this would have been a good end to
the game okay instead we we had this
weird stuff like 60 moves are useless
moving around alright thanks for
watching